Hi I'm Ellen
And I'm Diana.
And we're sitting
here in MoMA's conservation studio.
We're conservators. I work in sculpture and
I've been here for five years.
And I work in paintings and I've been here
for seven months as a graduate intern.
How do we hold our hands?
"Whatever is natural"
Objects that come through the conservation
studio often tell their own stories if you
look closely enough.
So we've made a lot of videos in the past.
Whether it's Yves Klein, or Andy Warhol,
or Frank Lloyd Wright, and we've received a lot
of good questions. Zoe asked "Is that
a special flashlight they keep using?
Does it use a different hue or wavelength
of light?
It's an odd looking flashlight."
David Robot says "Why are some individuals
in this feature wearing gloves when handling art
while others are not?"
Good question David.
That's a great question.
Alexis asks "Okay but what happened to her
head restoration?
Rolling eyes emoji."
Good point.
We are trying something new here at MoMA, since
we've got such great questions from you in
the comments section of our YouTube channel,
we thought we would do a Live Q&A to let people
ask questions as they come to them.
So send us any questions you might have in
the comments section down below or submit
them at 3PM on Wednesday.
In the meantime check out some of the videos
that we've posted in the past here, and here,
and here, and here, and there - and here.